[MUSIC PLAYING]
MICHELLE CASBON: Hi,
and welcome to episode
number 177 of the weekly
"Google Cloud Platform" Podcast.
I'm Michelle, and I'm here with
my colleague, Mark Mirchandani.
Hi, Mark.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Hi Michelle.
How are you today?
MICHELLE CASBON: I'm doing well.
How about you?
MARK MIRCHANDANI: I'm
doing very, very good.
And I'd like to take
this chance to call out
that May, which is the month
that we're currently in,
is Mental Health
Awareness Month.
MICHELLE CASBON: Mental
Health Awareness Month--
what exactly does that mean?
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So
I have a vague idea
of what it means, and
through some readings,
and a lot of tweet
conversations, and people
just kind of promoting
this idea that, hey, it's
important to take some time and
recognize that sometimes you
need to take a step back.
Sometimes you need to take
some time for yourself.
I think there's a lot
of negative stereotypes
about going to therapy.
And there's a lot
of ideas out there
that people are starting
to talk about them more.
And I think it's important
to raise awareness of it.
And that's why I
think that having
a month dedicated
to helping people
understand what mental
health awareness is
and why it's so
important for people
to kind of focus in on
not overloading themselves
with work, taking
time for themselves,
setting up an environment
where they feel good--
all of these kind of things are
really important to focus on.
And so that's why it's
kind of cool that there's
a month dedicated to it.
MICHELLE CASBON:
Yeah, so I really
like the fact that we
are talking about it,
that we're sort of normalizing
it, and making it clear
that there's no shame in it.
It's a way of taking
care of ourselves
in the same way we take
care of our physical health.
One of the best phrasing for
this is from a book by Brené
Brown, one of my
favorite authors.
So she describes it as if we
are exhaling all the time,
we need to be inhaling.
And Mental Health
Awareness Month
is a time for us to inhale,
so that we can exhale.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Oh, very interesting.
I'm going to have to
check that book out.
MICHELLE CASBON:
It's a good one.
I believe that one was from
"Braving the Wilderness,"
which was one of the most
recent ones that I read.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Gotcha.
Maybe we'll put a link
down in the show notes.
MICHELLE CASBON: Great idea.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Perfect.
Well, onto the main
content, today,
we have a very, very,
very, very, very--
I said six very-- seven very
cool interview with-- well,
why don't you introduce him?
MICHELLE CASBON: That
was a lot of verys.
So I agree that it was
a fascinating interview
with our friend John Bohannon.
So he co-presented a
session with me at Next,
and so we ask him a little
bit about his work, his path
into data science,
and how he got
to where he is now, which is a
director of science at Primer,
a startup here in the Bay Area.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Which
as a teaser, I mean,
this interview was wild, right?
I mean, we heard so
many cool stories.
I'm just remembering all the
fun things that we talked about.
It's a really, really
good interview.
Sorry-- a really, really,
really, really, really, really,
really good interview.
MICHELLE CASBON: It was one
of my favorites, for sure.
He's just a fascinating person.
But before we get to that, we
have a really exciting question
of the week that follows up
from our conversation with John.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: We
do, but even before we
get to the question
of the week, we're
going to do our cool
thing of the week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MICHELLE CASBON: Cool thing of
the week-- there are so many.
This is the week right
after Google I/O.
We were both there last week.
We had so much to do.
It was an action packed week.
So how do we condense that
into cool things of the week?
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Well, I'm glad
you asked because as it turns
out, all of the sessions
that happened at I/O,
and actually, all
the sessions that
happened at Next, which
wasn't that long ago--
all of those are available on
YouTube for people to re-watch.
Now there is a ton
of sessions at both.
And as you can imagine,
Google Cloud Next
had a ton of cloud content.
I/O had some cloud content, but
there was a lot of other talks
there, especially focusing
on other Google things,
like Android, and
Chrome, and so on.
So all of those talks
are available on YouTube.
If you go to the GCP Cloud
YouTube channel, as well
as the links we'll probably
put down in the show notes,
you can check out all
these different sessions.
You can kind of
read through them
and see what they're about,
and see who was talking,
and kind of catch
up on the topics
that you think were interesting.
But I know that
while we were there,
I was hanging out mostly
at the community booth,
talking with people, looking at
some of the new announcements.
But you had a chance to
actually go to some sessions.
So what was your
favorite session?
What was your favorite Code Lab?
And what was your
favorite Sandbox?
MICHELLE CASBON: Oh, so
many great questions.
So if you don't want to go
through all of the videos
from I/O, if you just
want a shortcut to what
was my favorite
session by far, that
would have to be the session
where Taylor Wilson interviewed
Michio Kaku.
So he is one of my
favorite scientists.
I've been reading
his books for years.
He's been on so
many PBS programs.
He's a very
public-facing scientist,
and there's not that
many of them out there.
So he's been pretty
transformational for me.
And what I really enjoyed
about the session--
it was sort of a
fireside chat format.
So Taylor has a lot
in common with him,
and you could tell that this
scientist, in particular,
was very formative for
Taylor's early years.
And so he was just so excited
to be interviewing him,
and there was so much
energy in the room.
And he asked such
intelligent questions,
and there was so much
overlap in their backgrounds
that it was just really
fascinating to watch.
It was not only a
fascinating interview,
but the interviewer was
also just really on point.
So I recommend that session.
It was by far my favorite.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So
that would definitely
be one of the great videos
to check out on YouTube.
So what about the Sandboxes?
I mean, there are a lot
of really cool demos
out there that
people could actually
get hands-on and
play around with
from, again, a wide
variety of Google products.
Which ones did you
kind of like the best?
MICHELLE CASBON: My
favorite would be
the one called AI on the Edge.
This was created by a
few of our co-workers.
Gabe Weiss, Noah
Negrey, and Yu-Han Liu,
who are both on my team, and
Gus, or Luis Gustavo Martins--
they all put this together.
And the cool thing about
that is the Sandboxes
are physical instantiations
of these projects.
And so it was like a living--
do you remember on "The Price is
Right" the Plinko boards?
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Oh, absolutely.
Everyone remembers the
Plinko boards, right?
It's the best game.
MICHELLE CASBON: So you
have that round token
that sort of makes its way
down and drops into a slot.
So the cool thing
about this is that it
used TensorFlow Lite to
identify the number that
was on the token, and
then it would drop it down
into the right slot
according to the number that
was written on the token.
It was super cool.
So there were a
couple parts to this.
There was image recognition
for recognizing the number.
And I believe that was
an on-device edge TPU.
And then there was also
the object recognition,
which was an Android app.
All of that was using
TensorFlow Lite--
so different types of hardware.
And the models that they used--
digit detection was
taken from AutoML,
and then the object detection
was using Mobilenet.
And the cool thing about that
is that all the code that
ran that will be open sourced.
Gabe is essentially
opening it this week.
So by the time show comes
out, it should be out.
And you'll be able to see all
the code that went into it,
everything that went behind it.
And he is also in the
process of writing
a blog post, or several.
So stay tuned on the GCP blog
for a written description
of everything that
he put together.
So you, too, can feel like
you were at I/O to view
the AI on the Edge Sandbox.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: That's the
best part about it, right?
Because if you didn't
get a chance to come,
the sessions are out on YouTube.
A lot of the code-- hopefully,
not just Gabe's demo--
are going open source.
There's still a lot
of hands-on stuff
that you probably
can't replicate,
which is why you should probably
come to the next year's I/O.
But if you weren't
able to make it,
there are lots and lots of cool
ways to catch up with that.
Not only that, but Code Labs
are another great way, right?
MICHELLE CASBON: Yeah, so that's
where I spent most of my time,
in the Code Lab section.
And my favorite lab
was the one that
uses a SparkFun edge board.
So this one also uses
TF Lite, which is
what was powering Gabe's demo.
So it's AI on a
microcontroller with TF Lite.
And I had seen this
a few weeks before
by one of the lead
researchers on the project,
but at I/O was the
first time where
users could come together.
And they had all the
written instructions,
and they got to do
this themselves.
So it walked them
through, on the board,
creating these models,
putting it onto the board.
And then you could
yell at the board.
It was a speech recognizer.
And then the right colored
light would go off,
and so you had throughout
the Code Labs people
just randomly screaming,
yes, yes, no, yes, no, no!
MARK MIRCHANDANI: I think I
saw something very similar
with animals, and
people had to scream out
the animal noises, which was
an interesting demo as well.
[ELEPHANT TRUMPETING]
MICHELLE CASBON: That was the
highlight of Code Labs for me,
was that one lab.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Oh, that's awesome.
And one of the other cool
things that was at I/O
was the Detox Zone,
and which we were just
talking about mental
health awareness
and how important it is.
MICHELLE CASBON: Absolutely.
So that was probably my
favorite miscellaneous zone.
I really appreciated that
there was a place for people
to sort of retreat.
What I loved about I/O--
and it was so
different from Next--
it was more of a developer
festival atmosphere,
so it was all outdoors.
And it was much
different from Next.
So Next is in Moscone.
I/O was outdoors,
and you were part
of nature, which I appreciated.
And this digital
detox zone was kind of
off to the side in a corner.
And I think my
favorite part about it
is that there was a woman
at a booth with a typewriter
offering poems.
So you could just walk
up and get a poem.
And she didn't
even use a laptop.
And it was literally
just a piece of paper
that she handed to you.
It was lovely.
So in the middle of
this detox garden,
it was a fantastic
contrast to the rest
of the sort of overwhelming
festival atmosphere.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So it's
a really great experience.
Obviously, for people
who do get a chance,
it's super, super awesome.
If you don't, we do our
best to try and get as much
of that experience out there.
But there probably just
isn't quite any way
to replicate it,
other than showing up.
MICHELLE CASBON: That's right.
So come next year.
It was my first I/O,
and I am definitely
going back next year.
It was fantastic.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Awesome to hear.
Well, I don't want to delay
our conversation with John
any longer.
So shall we dive into that?
MICHELLE CASBON:
Let's get started.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
All right.
Welcome, everyone.
We're very happy to have our
special guest today, John
Bohannon, here from Primer.
He's the director
of science there.
JOHN BOHANNON: Hi.
MICHELLE CASBON: I'm your
host, Michelle Casbon.
I'm a developer programs
engineer here at Google Cloud.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: And co-host
Mark Mirchandani, developer
advocate here at Google Cloud.
MICHELLE CASBON: And we're very
excited about today's episode.
So John and I, we did a session
last week at Google Next.
And I was fascinated.
So meeting John and
preparing for our session,
I just learned so
many things about him.
And I had to invite
him onto the show
to tell us more because
there are so many rabbit
holes to go down.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: And
you've been telling me
about this for this recording.
MICHELLE CASBON: That's right.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So it's
super exciting for me
to kind of understand.
And we were talking
before the recording,
and I think John has a lot
of cool content to share.
But before we get
into that, John,
can you tell us who you
are and what you do?
JOHN BOHANNON: Hey.
So I'm John Bohannon,
and these days,
I'm designing
artificial intelligence
to essentially read and write,
so that humans don't have to.
MICHELLE CASBON: That
sounds very exciting.
Is this because humans are lazy
or because maybe their results
are better?
JOHN BOHANNON: No,
humans work very hard.
And in fact, the
things we're building
are most useful
for the humans who
work really hard, whose job
involves reading and writing.
So broadly speaking, if
your job is an analyst--
you could be in government,
or banking, or corporate,
or even a journalist,
which is something
that I've done in my life--
it kind of boils down
to the same thing.
You spend the first
half of your day reading
way more than you could possibly
read, second half writing,
make sense of what you read, and
help someone make a decision,
or inform the public, or
inform the decision maker.
We try and automate
as much as possible
of that stack of tasks.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
So what does that
mean when you say automate
something like reading?
How do you do that?
JOHN BOHANNON: So for
example, when I first
joined Primer, when
we were very small,
I was leading an effort to build
a product called Primer Science
that reads papers for you.
And so it was a really
weird situation,
kind of like a snake eating its
own tail, I soon discovered.
Because I found myself
using this thing in order
to more efficiently
find scientific papers
that describe the
latest techniques
that I needed to
build the thing.
So I was basically
making something
that would help me make it.
And we've come a long way.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Well,
it's been a good chat.
Thanks for joining, everybody.
No, I mean, it's very confusing.
But the idea that you're
trying to write something
to help power itself is
kind of a scary concept,
in a lot of ways.
JOHN BOHANNON: I think
it's actually less scary.
So this is not
singularity stuff.
This is honestly human
augmentation stuff.
Even in a dream scenario
where technologies
that augment humans go
way beyond what we think
is possible currently,
at the end of the day,
this thing is not aimed towards
becoming a terminator robot.
[OMINOUS MUSIC]
It's aimed at making humans
that are much better at whatever
they care about.
MICHELLE CASBON: Right, so
give us an example of a way
that your system
has helped humans.
How has it made
their jobs easier
or made them more productive?
JOHN BOHANNON: Yeah,
so for example,
we have a customer who is a
health insurance company, one
of the biggest in the world.
And they have hundreds
of medical policies.
And there is a team of humans
whose job it is to constantly--
and I mean around the clock--
do scientific review to make
sure that those policies are up
to date.
And it's a legal
requirement, but also
a functional requirement.
If you're going to have
policies that cover the latest
techniques and diseases
as we learn about them,
someone has to actually
keep up with the science.
And that is an impossible task.
Even for that team,
which is a big team who
are really good
at this, there are
on order of at least 10 times
too many papers to read--
at least.
So what they do is
they take shortcuts,
like we all do as humans.
They rely on advice from people.
They read review papers.
Then, hopefully,
that review paper
kind of covered
enough that I don't
have to read all the
things that went into it.
And also just random sampling.
I think that is actually
the main technique humans
use when there's too
much for them to do,
is they just kind
of random sample
and hope that they're more or
less covering whatever it is.
So anyway, we have
this system set up
to just read all PubMed
papers for them constantly.
And there are classifiers that
are working in the background
to help them find the
things that are actually
relevant to any given policy.
They still have to read papers.
They still have to
make sense of stuff.
But they get a huge compression
of that information.
So everything is topic modeled,
and binned, and summarized.
And the most impactful papers
as described in the news or even
on Twitter are all being
kind of sequenced together
and compressed.
MICHELLE CASBON: Nice, so
you're saving people time.
You're helping
them do their jobs.
Where did you come
up with this idea?
Where did the idea for
this system come from?
JOHN BOHANNON: Oh, I
mean, originally, this
was the first thing
built at Primer,
and it was just a prototype.
We know we're onto
something with automating
reading and writing.
If we can do it on a
really hard document
type-- a scientific paper.
So it was really
just a prototype.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: It kind of
reminds me of the college days,
when I mean, really, I'm sure
a lot of the college people
have kind of come up
with these shortcuts
naturally because that's
how the human brain worked.
Especially where-- I don't
know about y'all in college,
but I was maybe not exactly
an exemplary student.
But the idea was you had a
tremendous amount of resources
that you needed
to kind of consume
in order to usually turn out a
paper or something like that.
And so there are all kinds of--
you get the short versions.
You get these summaries.
It sounds like that
is probably something
that is pretty instilled
into what humans naturally
kind of tend to
do, especially when
you get more and more complex
things, like scientific papers.
JOHN BOHANNON: Yeah.
And it's not just
the reading side.
So we also try and write the
first draft of things for you.
The requirement here is
not to make it perfect,
ready to publish.
The goal is do better
than a blank page.
Get something together that
you can work with quickly.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: And
how is that process,
going from blank page to what
I assume the first couple
renditions were maybe
not necessarily the most
readable of papers?
JOHN BOHANNON: Oh, well, I
mean, the cool thing is just
over the past two years of
building technology at Primer,
I've covered the whole
arc of approaches.
So in the beginning, you start
with rule based systems--
heuristics.
You just write exactly what will
be written with substitutions.
If you get this as data,
then say it this way.
Insert thing.
It's like Madlibbing, but it can
get really, really complicated.
And in fact, that's why
people ultimately turn away
from these systems, is like
if you have a problem that
is sufficiently complex,
no amount of rule writing
is going to get you there.
It's just too brittle.
You can't capture the
complexity of the world.
Beyond that, what you can do
is use extractive techniques.
So you have input
documents, and you
have a system that finds the
bits of those documents that
are most relevant to whatever
the need is, and then assembles
them together,
Frankenstein style.
And it mostly works.
One thing that's
really nice is you're
guaranteed that any given
sentence that the system says
will at least be a reasonable
sentence because it
was written by a human.
What you're not guaranteed is
that the whole thing actually
works at that paragraph
or document level.
And then the dream
is abstractive,
where you give the system
access to the English language,
or even just the English
alphanumeric character system.
And it goes sequence
to sequence.
Basically, things come in.
It decides what
to say, basically
word by word or character by
character, and spits out text.
The problem with that is it
runs off the rails very quickly
and becomes incoherent.
No one has solved that problem.
In fact, people
right here at Google
have done some of the most
groundbreaking work in this
and still haven't cracked it.
So the big news that came
out a month or two ago
was that OpenAI had made a
universal language model, which
is sort of the new
hotness in NLP, that
was capable of generating
totally coherent text,
paragraphs at a time.
And it is true that often,
not always, it can do that.
But it's basically
just like sleepwalking.
You can't tell it what to say.
It won't say anything
actually useful.
But it will spit out
locally coherent text.
That's where we are
with state of the art.
And there's actually
another chapter
to this saga that's going
to be starting soon.
And we're playing a
small part in that.
We've got a paper coming
out in "Archive" tomorrow,
which is we are going to be
introducing a new way to do
text generation that reframes
the problem as what's
called question answering.
So in that case, it's
kind of like blurring
the line between the extractive
and abstractive techniques.
So in extractive,
you're only allowed
to grab what humans have said
and stick it in front, one
after the other.
In abstractive, you
just read, and then you
grab whatever you want
from a dictionary.
We've blurred the
line between the two
by reframing this as,
you're asking a question
and then looking into the text
as a dictionary for the answer.
So the whole text
becomes, essentially,
the vocabulary on offer, which
can range from a single comma--
you could grab that and say,
yep, that's what I want to say.
Or you can grab
an entire sentence
and say, oh, it says exactly
what I need to say right now.
Boom.
And so you have a more
limited expressivity.
But we're finding
that, actually, it's
starting to pass the Turing
test with text generation.
So the problem that we are
publishing about tomorrow
is on headline generation.
You can imagine a headline as
the shortest summary possible
of a document.
A news headline is
essentially trying to tell you
what this article's about.
But if you get anything
wrong, it's totally useless.
You can get away with
a bunch of fudges
if you have to generate
a paragraph long summary.
It's still functional.
You know what the
document's about.
But if you change one word--
x bombs y versus y bombs x--
they have totally
different meanings.
And of course, if you replace
one those words with the word
wagon, then it's also
just totally meaningless.
So by making the
system concentrate
on the vocabulary of the text,
we just happily discovered
that it does amazingly well.
So humans, vast
majority of the time,
can't tell which
headline is actually
machine or human-generated.
And in the majority
of cases, they
judge not knowing
which is which.
We have them score
these headlines,
and they, more
often than not, say
that the machine-generated
headline was as good or better
than the original.
And by the way, this was
all built on Google's Bert,
so thank you, Google
Research, for that.
MICHELLE CASBON: Nice.
Yeah, I hear a lot of
positive things about Bert.
And it's really
fascinating to see how
you've made this progression.
So I've seen the
Quiksilver codebase,
and it's just fascinating
to see some of those rules
that you generated.
There are literal
functions that just
generate very specific things.
But then that's
combined with, I can
see how you've progressed
as you've been there
and come up with
these new ideas.
So I'm really excited to
see how the research that's
in your paper--
how that's reflected
in the codebase.
JOHN BOHANNON: Yeah.
And also, I think
everyone's going to start
using this technique now.
It'll find applications far
beyond what we're using it for.
MICHELLE CASBON: By the time
this episode is published,
we'll have a link for you,
and everyone can read it.
And what's fascinating is that
it's not your typical sequence
to sequence generator.
It's this totally new way
of looking at the problem,
reframing it, and
it's fascinating.
JOHN BOHANNON: And it's made
possible by these big beautiful
universal language
models that Google
released that, from an AI
engineering point of view,
is just a dream.
All the hard work has been done,
and you just pop off the head
and put on a different thing.
It's like LEGO.
It's beautiful.
So we literally just took a
standard question answer head
and stuck it on top of Bert.
And then of course, we had
to do the training and all
that stuff, but it works.
MICHELLE CASBON: The
other thing I think
is fascinating about that
is having seen your code,
I was very surprised
to learn that you
don't have a classical
computer science background.
So how did you get into building
something like Quicksilver?
JOHN BOHANNON: Long
and winding path.
So I started off as a
molecular biologist,
studying the
evolution of bacteria.
And fun fact-- I
designed a pregnancy
test for codfish that worked.
But then my PhD was
on a soil bacterium
and trying to reconstruct,
essentially, Darwinian laws
using experimental evolution.
And then--
MICHELLE CASBON: Wait, can we
go back to the pregnancy test?
What was that useful for?
JOHN BOHANNON: Oh, well, the
National Marine Fisheries
Service needs to survey
the cod population.
And at the time,
what you had to do
was pull up net loads
of fish, cut them open,
and weigh organs, and see
if the females were gravid--
having lots of eggs.
And not only is it really
inefficient as a sampling
technique, but of course,
you can't throw the fish back
after you've cut them open.
And so that, among
other reasons,
was motivation to get a
more sophisticated approach
to population surveys.
MICHELLE CASBON: So you saved
cod lives by developing a test.
JOHN BOHANNON: I did.
I am responsible for
some number of cod lives.
MICHELLE CASBON: Excellent.
OK, continue.
JOHN BOHANNON: And
so, then, I wanted
to do something different,
instead of diving
into the next lab
job for my postdoc.
And so I sent a letter to the
editor of "Science," saying,
I hear that you
might have some kind
of interesting opportunities
for someone like me.
I'm a molecular biologist
and a playwright.
MICHELLE CASBON: Who has
saved all these cod lives.
JOHN BOHANNON: No, I
didn't even bring that up.
I think it was
literally as weird
as, I'm a molecular
biologist playwright.
Because I was--
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Well,
the playwright stuff,
you haven't even
talked about yet.
JOHN BOHANNON: Well,
so during my PhD,
I was spending way too much of
my time doing extracurriculars,
among which was a lot of
stagewriting and acting.
And what I later found out
was that my letter circulated
as a joke at "Science."
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Well, I mean, it's
good to be known
for something, but.
JOHN BOHANNON: Well, that's
the beauty of this approach.
So that was one of n spores
that I sent out on the winds,
trying to find out what my
next life chapter should be.
And so when I got a response,
I was kind of surprised
and forgotten it, mostly,
that I had even sent that one.
And I got a response
from the news editor
of "Science," who, in a
former life, was a novelist.
He's now at the New York
Academy of Sciences.
And he said, well, you have
an interesting background.
I think we have a
news internship.
Would that be a fit?
And I was in England
and doing my PhD.
And not far away
at Cambridge, they
had just set up the first
international office
for "Science."
And the news editor
there was just
setting up shop and kind of
wanted to have a news intern,
but no one knew about it.
And so I just snuck
in, not a single piece
of writing to my name.
MICHELLE CASBON: Wow.
What year was that?
Because I was in
Cambridge as well.
JOHN BOHANNON: 2002.
MICHELLE CASBON: 2002, I
was not at Cambridge yet.
So you started out as a news
intern in Cambridge in England.
JOHN BOHANNON: Yeah.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: With a PhD.
JOHN BOHANNON: Yes.
And within a couple
months of doing that,
I found myself in an
obscure city in China
investigating a body factory
where human cadavers are
turned into artwork.
[DRAMATIC MUSIC]
MICHELLE CASBON: What?
JOHN BOHANNON: Yes, where
my mission was to get proof,
if it existed, that
this body factory
was sourcing its human cadavers
from the Chinese government.
It is the number one executer
of prisoners in the world,
so it seems like a
great source of bodies.
And I got confirmation
they were getting bodies
from the Chinese state.
MICHELLE CASBON: Wow.
JOHN BOHANNON: So when
I had that experience.
I basically never looked back.
I was like, oh, this is what
I'm supposed to be doing.
And I then did that
for more than a decade.
MICHELLE CASBON: And you
investigated many more exciting
topics.
JOHN BOHANNON: Yes.
MICHELLE CASBON: What
was your favorite topic
that you ever covered?
JOHN BOHANNON: It depends
on the flavor of favor.
MICHELLE CASBON: OK, so--
JOHN BOHANNON: It depends on
what you mean by favorite.
MICHELLE CASBON: What was
the most interesting story
you wrote about?
JOHN BOHANNON: So
interesting to the audience
was probably some of the
weirder stories that I've done.
I organized and ran the
first scientific conference
within a virtual game
world, "World of Warcraft,"
with the director of
human-centered computing
at the NSF.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: The real
question is, what level was he?
JOHN BOHANNON: 70,
which, at the time, was--
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Of course.
That was the max then.
I just don't know
if it still is now.
Maybe.
JOHN BOHANNON: I don't either.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: But I mean,
that actually is now not
incredibly uncommon, right?
They've started to have a lot
of event-led meet-ups inside
of virtual worlds, whether
that is popular video games
or whether they've had all this
"Fortnite" stuff and all those.
I mean, it's been
tremendously interesting
to see the intersection
between real life
and where people want to bring
their interests into that,
even though they're not
related to the game.
So maybe you kind of pioneered
a little bit of that effort?
JOHN BOHANNON:
Yeah, I think I was
part of that that first wave.
And it does make things
possible that are just not
practical in the real world.
For example, for entertainment
during this big scientific
conference, we
went out on a raid,
and absolutely everyone got
killed in horrible ways.
And then we got to laugh
about it over virtual beers.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: The most
amazing thing I've heard.
JOHN BOHANNON: Yeah,
it was pretty great.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
That's awesome.
JOHN BOHANNON: But yeah, I think
interesting to me was embedding
with NATO forces in
Kandahar during the surge
in Afghanistan.
And I was there to try
and convince the military
to release a data set.
They didn't realize it, but that
was my actual secret mission.
And I succeeded.
And so I engineered the first
ever honest public release
of civilian casualty data from
the United Nations and NATO
forces.
And I say honest
because they actually
used to do that routinely
during the Vietnam War.
The US military would actually
publish casualty numbers
in the newspaper.
This was during the period of
the war of attrition, the idea
being that if we were killing
10 communists for every one US
soldier, we were winning.
And so it was actually
my stats professor.
When he was a grad student, he
started analyzing those numbers
and proved that they
were being cooked.
Because the distribution
of the final digit
was not following a random
distribution at all.
Can you guess which numbers
were abnormally infrequent?
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Infrequent?
MICHELLE CASBON: 0.
JOHN BOHANNON: You got it.
If you're going to
publish fake numbers,
you better make it
feel real by saying
that 27 communists were killed.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So if you have
one takeaway from this episode,
it's to make sure you correctly
falsify numbers by using
an actual random distribution.
JOHN BOHANNON: Exactly.
If you're going to cook
the books, do it right.
MICHELLE CASBON: So how were
you able to convince them
to release this honest data?
JOHN BOHANNON: So first of all,
it was just a lot of face time
with officers in Kandahar,
and visiting hospitals,
and just sort of being
there with the teams.
So--
MICHELLE CASBON: And you were
there as press as a journalist?
JOHN BOHANNON: Mm-hmm.
And so I learned a lot about
the US military-- well, NATO,
as well, but I was mostly around
a lot of US military officers.
But I really did not
realize until I spent a lot
time with them how much it is
like a face-to-face culture.
It's such a vast and
inefficient bureaucracy
that think that everything
is just sort of-- we
even have a term for it.
Oh, that was done with
military precision.
And that does mean
something, but actually how
things move in such a huge
organization is not precise.
It's very efficient.
And basically, when
things get done,
it's because people are
really invested in it,
and they make it happen.
And so I feel like a lot of
what I did in Afghanistan
was just convincing the
right people that this
is the kind of
thing you should do.
This data is not going to
do any harm to release.
It will do a lot of good.
And so I basically
asked for a little bit,
and I got a little bit.
And I was like, oh,
this is really--
no one's ever seen this,
and this really helps.
I make the case that
you were describing
about how, for example, this
new approach to roadblocks
has started to reduce
civilian casualties.
If you give me a
little bit more data,
I could probably show that has
made a difference in regions
where you stood up
that new technique.
Release a little bit more.
I was like, oh, that's
really interesting.
You know what else?
This other thing that you really
care about-- if you've got
the data to show it.
And slowly but surely, I had
everything but some patches.
And I was like, well, why not
just release the whole thing?
And it just became a lot easier.
But there's no way I could
have done that from a distance.
Just no way at all.
MICHELLE CASBON:
And what did you
do with that data set once you
released it, once you had it?
JOHN BOHANNON: Published
it in "Science,"
released it publicly.
MICHELLE CASBON: What did other
people do with that data set?
Do you know?
JOHN BOHANNON: A lot of
analysis, a lot of advocating.
There was a more
than two-fold gap
in the number of casualties
reported by the military
compared to the UN observers.
And we could see that
for the first time,
and that had to
be accounted for.
So it just basically
turned on the discourse.
Everyone suddenly had
something to talk about.
I think it just planted
a flag in history
that if you are going to
be a huge occupying force,
for better or worse, you
better be transparent.
But we now have conflicts in
Syria, where there is no one,
essentially, to
hold accountable.
So it's not a fix for
our bigger problems.
But it was important
at the time.
MICHELLE CASBON: OK, so at this
point, you're a journalist.
You've been traveling
around the world, following
these really exciting stories.
So how do you get from that
kind of lifestyle to AI?
JOHN BOHANNON: Python.
MICHELLE CASBON: Python.
JOHN BOHANNON: Of
course it was Python.
MICHELLE CASBON: Like the snake,
because you're a biologist?
JOHN BOHANNON: No, the--
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Wow, good callback.
JOHN BOHANNON: Pretty good.
No, the coding language.
I had a project involving
the Google Ngrams data set.
So the team at Harvard that
built the data set, as well
as the Ngram Viewer, which
is alive and well today
and really cool, it grew out
of the Google Books project.
Those two people, grad
students at Harvard,
were just friends of mine.
I was basically
like moonlighting
as a researcher in that group.
And so when that paper came
out on the cover of "Science,"
along with it was
a story that I did
about the history
of science as seen
through the lens
of that data set.
And it was a really
frustrating experience for me
because I was beholden to
this undergrad at Harvard who
had to do the very basic
data manipulations for me.
Because the data
sets were far too
large to deal with
in spreadsheets,
and I didn't know
how to code yet.
And I knew exactly
what I wanted to do.
I could write it
down, like do this.
But I couldn't
express it in code.
And so the day after
that got published,
I was like, enough is enough.
I've gotta learn how to solve
these problems for myself.
And well, I got obsessed.
Once you have a
hammer, everything
looks like a coding problem.
So--
MICHELLE CASBON: I don't know
what you're talking about.
Using Python to solve every
single problem you encounter?
No one in this room has
ever done that before.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: That wouldn't
be a realistic scenario.
JOHN BOHANNON: So I got
obsessed about coding.
And then slowly
but surely, I went
from being a foreign
correspondent who runs around
to places like China and
Afghanistan to find stories,
to someone who tries
to get data sets
and pull out stories
worth telling from data.
And then it became like
building things that read data.
And then it became
like, wow, maybe
I could actually contribute
to open source coding
and then share some
of these solutions.
And then I moved to the Bay Area
to do a visiting postdoc thing
at Berkeley in their new
Data Science Institute.
And my friend Sean Gourley,
just across the water
in San Francisco, had a
new startup called Primer.
And he'd tried this
trick on me before when
he had a startup before this.
He was like, just come.
Come over, and we have really
cool resources and data.
You should just come play.
And now that I lived in the
same city, I was like, ugh.
All right, all right, all right.
And after like one
day at Primer--
well, there were only 10
people, so it was a big room
with a bunch of empty desks.
And I'm sitting there
working on the problem
at the time, which was I wanted
to make a quote extractor.
So this was 2015,
and I wanted to get
all the quotes of Donald Trump.
My journalist colleagues
were chasing their own tails,
trying to catch him
contradicting himself
in any of his copious
publicly quoted statements.
And I was surprised to learn
there is no database of quotes
from him, nor is there a
database of quotes from anyone.
And so I started to look
into it, got on Github,
found that someone had made a
good first attempt at a quote
extractor.
And then the project
kind of petered out.
And I actually tracked down
that person, and I was like,
what happened to this?
I'd love to take this further.
Why did you stop?
And he was like,
because it's hard,
and I need to get
paid for something.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: What
about it makes it hard?
JOHN BOHANNON: So you'd
think that you could just
make a regular expression
that would find anything
between quotation marks.
But--
MICHELLE CASBON:
Famous last words.
JOHN BOHANNON: Well,
you're also going
to capture anything
that's in quotation marks,
like scare quotes.
Here's the review of
the movie, "Titanic,"
where "Titanic" is in quotes.
Now you've essentially
got a huge source of junk
in things that are
supposed to be quotes.
Then you've got an
even harder problem.
Let's say you did
have clean quotes.
You've just got the perfect
data set of truly quoted
human statements.
How do you figure
out who said it?
So that's the problem
of attribution.
So you could imagine making a
regular expression that will
capture human names downstream--
you know, "said so-and-so"
or "so-and-so says."
And you might be able
to capture those spans,
but it's a lot trickier
than you think.
People basically have
a near infinite way
of expressing that
someone said something
and attributing it to them.
And that didn't even touch
the he said, she said.
Now you have a problem that's
a really classic hard problem
in NLP called entity
co-reference resolution, where,
given a text that mentions
multiple people that
uses anaphora, like he and
she, him and her, his and hers,
you have to figure
out who corresponds,
which entity
actually corresponds
to what bit of text.
Now you're in
uncharted territory.
So it's just really hard.
So day one at Primer, I sat next
to this crazy Ukrainian named
Leonard that Michelle has met.
He's an absolute dear, and--
MICHELLE CASBON: He is
hilarious and wonderful.
JOHN BOHANNON: Yeah,
he's really great.
MICHELLE CASBON: And
very skilled at NLP.
JOHN BOHANNON: Yes,
he is, as we call it,
a mensch worth mentioning.
MICHELLE CASBON: Yes.
Great description.
JOHN BOHANNON: On
day one, [INAUDIBLE]
what are you working on?
And I was like digging
into this quote stuff.
And he's like, oh, yeah,
we already solved that.
The harder problem is this one.
And he tries to show me
what he was working on.
And by the end of the day,
I was like, OK, I'll join.
MICHELLE CASBON:
These are my people.
JOHN BOHANNON: OK, fine.
I could probably spend
the next six months
of my life doing unpaid
work to try and fix quote
extraction for everyone else.
Or I could join a
startup that's trying
to pull all that together
into true automated reading
and writing.
MICHELLE CASBON: And I mean,
how can you say no to Leonard?
JOHN BOHANNON: He's a dear.
MICHELLE CASBON:
He is wonderful.
OK, so your common
thread up to this point
has been interesting
problems to solve,
data, and finding sort of
new ways of doing things
that other people haven't
seen before-- haven't applied
to those types of problems.
JOHN BOHANNON: Yeah.
MICHELLE CASBON: OK,
so how does dance tie
in to your interest in AI?
JOHN BOHANNON: Oh, yeah.
That's a weird
cul-de-sac in my life.
MICHELLE CASBON: Well, you
were already a playwright.
You're already used
to being onstage.
JOHN BOHANNON: So
OK, I was living
in Vienna, Austria as a foreign
correspondent in 2006 and 2007
when I had this party that
I was helping organize.
It was a New Year's Eve
party that didn't actually
happen on New Year's
Eve, but whatever.
It was round about
New Year's Eve.
And I wanted it to
be a dance party.
I just always feel disappointed
at a nice big party
when no dancing occurs.
I just feel like it's a
crime against humanity.
And so-- that's too strong.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: We've heard
about some different stories
today.
I feel like the
dance party might not
be at the top of the list.
JOHN BOHANNON: It's hard to
get people to dance in general.
And it's actually
surprisingly hard
to get a group of frustrated
scientists, grad students
to dance.
I don't know why that is.
It's just like, it's
a pretty tough crowd
to get to loosen up.
MICHELLE CASBON: I know
exactly why that is.
JOHN BOHANNON: Yeah, but
is it nature or nurture?
Are people who don't want to
dance becoming grad students?
Or is there something about
the grad life experience that
makes you not want to dance?
Unsolved problems.
So--
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
I'm sure there's
a machine learning algorithm
out there that could probably
figure this out for us.
JOHN BOHANNON: For all
you listening at home,
if you've got an
idea about this,
post it on Twitter
at #ReasonsForDance.
So--
MARK MIRCHANDANI: The
reasons for dance movement--
I could get into this.
JOHN BOHANNON: So I
proposed a dance contest
to motivate the
audience that were
all scientist grad students.
So I was like, you
have to dance your PhD.
So in a short dance, you
must express the basic idea,
the essence of your PhD, but
with no words, no jargon,
no PowerPoint slides.
You have to just dance it.
MICHELLE CASBON:
Which honestly, to me,
sounds harder than doing a PhD.
JOHN BOHANNON: Well,
there are some people
that feel the opposite.
And this contest
is basically-- it's
become a huge filter on the
world to find that population.
We almost do-- we being me
and "Science," the journal,
who hosts this
contest every year,
for 11 years and running--
we do minimal marketing.
Really, it's just like
a post on Facebook.
And we put out a
little story online.
People just come
out of the woodwork
from all over the world, from
countries all over the world,
and take part.
But the reason it turned
into a contest at all was
because after that party,
so long ago in Vienna,
we shot some good video of the
actual contest-- the dances--
and put it online.
And I wrote a story
for "Science" about it,
just for fun.
And then the emails started
coming in from scientists just
all over the world,
saying, I'm ready.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
People were excited.
JOHN BOHANNON: When does
next year's contest kick off?
MICHELLE CASBON:
You filled a gap.
There was a need.
JOHN BOHANNON: There was.
And I had no plans.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: No
one knew it existed.
JOHN BOHANNON: No
plans for this.
But then I was like, I
guess we do have to do it.
And because people were asking
from all over the world,
I had no money for this.
Can't do a live event.
So I was like, oh,
well, we could do it
as an online video contest.
And YouTube around
about 2007, 2008,
it was working pretty well.
So I was like, OK, put
your dances on YouTube,
send me the link, and I'll
assemble a judge of experts,
like I did the
first time around,
from the worlds of
science and dance.
And they'll determine
the winners.
And the prize when we started
was a one year subscription
to "Science."
MICHELLE CASBON: That's perfect.
JOHN BOHANNON: And it hasn't
gotten much grander than that.
It's like, you get 1,000 bucks
is as fancy as we've gotten.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Well, I
think it's because people
aren't doing it for the prize.
They're doing it for
the passion of it.
JOHN BOHANNON: Yeah.
Honestly--
MICHELLE CASBON: They
just need an excuse.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Which is exciting.
JOHN BOHANNON:
--that is exactly it.
They would have been
doing this anyway.
They probably already were
doing it in the shower, and--
MICHELLE CASBON: They
needed an audience.
JOHN BOHANNON: They just
needed the audience.
That's what this provides.
MICHELLE CASBON: OK,
so all of a sudden,
you have all these people
around the world describing
scientific topics
through dance--
JOHN BOHANNON: Yeah.
MICHELLE CASBON: --and
expressing themselves.
JOHN BOHANNON: Oh, by the
way, this past year's winner
was a PhD student in
Canada, who studies quantum
properties of materials.
And he not only organized
this awesome dance video,
but he wrote and performed
a song for that video.
It's like so over the top.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
I mean, if you're
going to go any
portion of the way,
you may as well go
all the way and get
your own original
composition as well.
JOHN BOHANNON: Yeah.
It's pretty amazing.
MICHELLE CASBON: I mean, he was
already doing it in the shower.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Exactly.
MICHELLE CASBON: So he
might as well record.
JOHN BOHANNON: It's
pretty amazing.
MICHELLE CASBON:
OK, so people are
describing scientific
topics through dance.
Of course, that's a natural leap
through applying AI to that.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Yeah, is it?
Is it, though?
Could you maybe clarify
that point a little bit?
JOHN BOHANNON: How
do you mean exactly?
MICHELLE CASBON: So I'm
trying to make the connection
between the workshop I went to.
There was this AI
and dance workshop.
There's this group here in San
Francisco that meets weekly.
And it's amazing.
And I was baffled at how
AI and dance came together.
And so I'm curious to hear
what the bridge was for you.
How did you get from
dancer PhD to AI and dance?
JOHN BOHANNON: So
yeah, that thing
that happens every Wednesday
is called Kinetech Arts.
And by the way,
it's a public event.
So all you Bay Area
people who are listening,
you are very welcome to join.
You can find it on meetup.com.
And it's essentially a bunch of
technologists who get together
with a bunch of mostly
dancers, but art people,
and we do experiments together.
So we'll wire up dancers
with motion capture suits
and then run an experiment
where we generate music
based on their movement.
For example, one time we
brought in the research group
from Berkeley who had that paper
out last year, in which you
learn how to dance on
a human skeleton model
by having the system just like
watch video of someone dancing
and then apply that movement to
a model of someone else's body.
So if you, Michelle, were to
take part, what would happen
is you would just
be walking around,
manipulating your limbs for a
while in a pretty random way,
so that it gets sort of
all the angles of you
and makes a model
of your skeleton.
And then it can apply any
dance it's ever learned to you
and generate a video of
you doing that dance.
So I mean, you can make videos
of people dancing ballet
at the level of the
Bolshoi, break dancing.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
The important part
is that's not deeply terrifying.
Because now we're
kind of getting
into that-- what is it from
the past couple of months
slash year?
JOHN BOHANNON: Deepfakes.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: It's this
whole deepfake concept, right?
This idea that you
can now basically
say, oh, video footage
is no longer reliable
because it's too
easy to simulate.
The master level that
we have now, you've
got all these intense AI
and ML properties that
are being put together
to say, anyone
can be caught doing
anything or saying anything
because we have
all the technology
required to simulate it.
JOHN BOHANNON: Yep.
And while applying dance
movement to someone's body,
it's hard to imagine how that
could go terribly wrong--
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Oh, I have
many, many instant ideas
of how that could go terribly.
But please.
JOHN BOHANNON: But I mean,
it's only a few steps away
from a lot of terrible things.
Yeah, I wish I could say
that we have enough time
to carefully think through
and make policies around this,
but it's already here.
And we don't have
those policies.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: And even
then, without those policies,
I mean, people are going to
play around with it, right?
I mean, this whole
community is driven
on open source in general.
People are encouraged to
experiment and play around
with things.
JOHN BOHANNON: Absolutely.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: And
so you naturally get
people who are like, oh,
I wonder if I can do this.
And then they do.
And then they're like, hey, I'm
going to go talk to my friends
about this.
And then you kind of just
build this entire boulder
that's kind of rolling
down a hill of like, wow,
these are things that
are completely unchecked.
And there's a lot of
kind of scary practice--
I mean, I know we're being
really vague about what
those details are,
but I think people
can use their imaginations.
There's a lot of really
scary stuff out there.
I don't even know how you
would kind of put organization
around it.
JOHN BOHANNON:
Yeah, I mean, that's
a whole policy discussion.
But essentially, the
best idea I've heard
is that you need to have
laws on the books that
make real consequences for
hurting people by reputation
or however it has
a negative impact.
You have to have laws on the
books that have consequences.
MICHELLE CASBON: And what I
really liked about that group
is they weren't just sort of
getting together in a room,
experimenting.
We started out the workshop
with the discussion,
and they asked some really
intriguing questions.
It was people who maybe don't
understand the technology very
well, trying to
understand it more
and asking important questions
that people who use technology
haven't thought of.
It was that coming together
of those two domains
that I found just
fascinating, that there
was so much crossover
and interests
and what can we achieve.
That's where innovation
has happened traditionally,
is when you got these two
intersecting fields that
come together and
like, oh, we haven't
looked at this problem from
that perspective before.
JOHN BOHANNON: Yep.
And what I love about
the event especially
is that it's not just one-sided.
It's not just naive people
from outside of science
ask hard questions that inspire
scientists to better explain
and think about their own stuff.
It also goes the other way.
So we had one night
not too long ago where
we were playing with a new
piece of technology that
senses your heartbeat
and transmits it
via router to whatever
you want it to go to.
And so we sent it
to, essentially,
the sound system of the
room-- very straightforward.
So you basically strap
this thing on to someone,
and suddenly the entire room
is engulfed in their heartbeat.
And so as they become
calm or excited,
essentially, everyone
experiences it.
And so it's kind of very
simple concept, well executed,
and then we then just
switched over to dance mode,
where we have some of the most
amazing people from the dance
community in San
Francisco just there,
helping to run this thing.
And they know how to take a
room of people, even non-movers,
people who aren't
used to being movers,
and make it safe for
them to start moving.
Suddenly the entire
room was basically
this spontaneous dance event.
And it was really beautiful.
And people just came
up to me afterwards,
who have never experienced
that, were like, that's amazing.
Is this every Wednesday?
And yeah, it's that easy.
You just get people in the
room with good intentions,
and you can do some
really cool stuff.
MICHELLE CASBON: Yeah,
that's fascinating.
I love that there are so
many aspects to your journey,
that you're not just someone
who's working on AI now,
but you're a person with
these very rich experiences,
this very rich background.
Is there anything
else you'd like
to share about your background?
What was your--
MARK MIRCHANDANI: We've gotten
a really big history of--
MICHELLE CASBON: We have.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
--all the cool things.
And I know that we've
probably gone a little long.
It would definitely
be useful to ask,
is there anywhere
you're going here soon?
Or is there anywhere
you're going to be?
Are there any cool dance
competitions coming up
that people should find you at?
JOHN BOHANNON: Well, let's see.
The big thing in
my life right now
is that the "Archive"
paper that we've
been working on for a while
is coming out tomorrow.
And let's see, beyond that--
MICHELLE CASBON: I
did want to ask you
what your favorite job was.
JOHN BOHANNON: Oh.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: I mean,
was it the saving the fish?
Was it working with the military
and getting the numbers?
Was it being a journ--
I mean, there are a lot of
jobs you've had, clearly.
MICHELLE CASBON: And I don't
think that's the full list.
What haven't you told us about?
MARK MIRCHANDANI: No, I'm
sure it's the truncated.
JOHN BOHANNON: I think there's
a special place in my heart
still for the year after
graduating from undergrad
before grad school, where I was
a nude model for art classes
at Hammersmith
and Mount Holyoke,
simply because it was pretty
well-paying at the time for me,
and they didn't
have enough males.
And I did it just
for life experience,
but actually, now
that I've done yoga,
I actually know what
I was tapping into.
But it was like my first
experience with meditation
and in a very unusual setting.
And I got paid to
meditate, basically.
MICHELLE CASBON: So
you were meditating
while people painted you?
JOHN BOHANNON: The best
time in that period
was working for one sculptor.
So I had to hold the same pose
for week after week after week.
And so it just whittles away
your awareness of your body.
At the same time,
it hyperconcentrates
your awareness of the body.
It's very hard to explain.
But I really have a very
sentimental recollection
of that job.
MICHELLE CASBON:
Of all the lessons
I expected to hear
from someone who
has experience as a nude
model, that was probably
the last one I expected to hear.
And I think it's amazing.
JOHN BOHANNON: What
did you expect to hear?
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
I'll cut it off
right there,
because I'm not sure
where it's going to go there.
But in talking to some
people, some people
have-- they've kind of
said, look, in some ways,
it's boring, right?
They're kind of sitting around.
They're like, you've got to do
something to occupy your mind,
because you have to hold still.
So actually, I think that
kind of concept of like, yeah,
you kind of end up meditating is
a really poignant one, but also
probably a really real one for
a lot of those people out there
who are just like, I
can't move for 45 minutes.
What am I going to do?
JOHN BOHANNON: Yeah, and I
discovered it accidentally.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Which is
the most beautiful part.
MICHELLE CASBON: And
it's an important life
skill that serves you
well today, I'm sure.
JOHN BOHANNON: I wish I
was better at it, but yeah.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: With
the modeling-- never mind.
Never mind.
MICHELLE CASBON:
There's still time.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Yeah, I think
we're just about out of time.
MICHELLE CASBON: All right.
Thank you, John.
It was awesome having you here.
I appreciate you taking
us through that journey
of your history--
JOHN BOHANNON: My pleasure.
MICHELLE CASBON: --and
sharing your experience.
JOHN BOHANNON: And for all you
listening, nice to meet you.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Thank
you so much, John.
MICHELLE CASBON: And now what
we've all been waiting for--
the question of the week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Well,
so we had a really, really
awesome conversation with John.
So I got a feeling it
might be tied to that.
MICHELLE CASBON: So the big
question that everyone's
wanting to know--
how can we be like John?
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Well,
that's a very tall order.
For everyone who just listened,
it was a great conversation.
We learned a lot about how John
took a really unique path, I
think, through life and did a
lot of very, very cool things,
but on top of that, is also now
kind of currently building out
really complex models.
And I think we've had
a kind of a recurring
theme in the past couple
of episodes whenever
we do talk about machine
learning, and saying like, hey,
it's a really high barrier.
So how do we be more like John?
But really, in this case,
is how do we kind of
get started with
machine learning
or build out some
of the stuff he's
learning without the many,
many years of experience
and kind of life challenges
that he worked through?
Well, in this case,
we've actually
just pushed out a great
blog post, which is also
a Code Lab, that really
looks at a walkthrough of how
to build an AutoML natural
language classifier.
And the beautiful
part about AutoML,
if you're not
familiar with it, is
it lets you build machine
learning models without really
writing any code, right?
So you kind of
send the data, you
classify what that
data looks like,
and then it trains a machine
learning model for you.
That, in itself, is magic.
But this walks through
how do you actually
put the magic in your hands?
How do you build that out?
How do you go from
here's a set of data,
to here's a working
machine learning prediction
model in actually a pretty
short period of time?
I walked through it,
and I was shocked
at how quick you
could kind of just
build this entire thing out.
I think it's always
surprising to see
all of the machine
learning in action.
And I don't know a lot
about machine learning.
So it's fascinating to see how
easy it is to dive in there.
MICHELLE CASBON: Yeah,
AutoML, in particular, it's
really interesting the way
they've built the service.
So it uses something
called transfer learning.
So the service trains a bunch
of models behind the scenes.
And then you come
in with your data,
and it sort of adds
your specific use case
on top of the models that
have already been built.
And it gives you a much
more personalized model.
But it's still very accurate
because of how they built it.
And it's a great way to get
started if you don't really
know much about deep
learning because it's a UI.
And you don't need
a whole lot of data,
and you can leverage
a lot of the hard work
by people who know a lot more
about deep learning than I do.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Which
is absolutely the bucket
that I fall in.
So I am more than
happy to take advantage
of kind of the cool resources
that have been built,
and this guide that
people can kind of, again,
just go right now
and step through.
So we'll make sure to have a
link to that in the show notes.
MICHELLE CASBON: Excellent.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: OK, great.
So before we wrap up, where
are we all going to be?
Anything cool coming up?
MICHELLE CASBON: Yeah, so
I'm headed out in a few days.
I'll be heading to
Barcelona for KubeCon EU.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Ooh, fancy.
MICHELLE CASBON: I'll be
there for a few weeks.
So I'm giving a
workshop on Kubeflow.
If you want an introduction
to Kubeflow pipelines,
my workshop is the place to be.
There will be a video of
it if you're not physically
in Barcelona for the event.
It's a publicly available Code
Lab, and there will be a video,
so you can follow along.
So if you're not there,
you won't have to miss out.
We'll add it to a
future show notes.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
I think the idea--
I mean, this is a big convention
for Kubernetes in general,
right?
MICHELLE CASBON: It is.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: And I
think that a lot of people
who can't make it out there--
similar to I/O and Next,
right-- the best
efforts go into try
and making this
content consumable.
But sometimes it can be hard
to replicate that conference
experience.
MICHELLE CASBON: Where
are you headed this week?
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Well, as per usual,
I'm going to bunker down and
stay here in the Bay Area.
I think we spent a lot of energy
going around Next and I/O.
But I don't tend to
travel that often,
which is also a big part of
my mental health awareness.
Because I'm sure that that might
be challenging if I traveled
as much as everyone else did.
Speaking of which, Mark
is over in Japan, right?
MICHELLE CASBON: He is.
He's in Japan this week.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: And
Gabi is in France.
So we have a lot of
traveling going on.
I mean, for people who
already kind of are based here
in the States, these are
some far distances to go.
So I would definitely
be exhausted.
I know John's out on the
East Coast here in New York.
And then Brian's traveling over
to, I think, Colorado soon.
MICHELLE CASBON: I believe so.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So there's
a lot of events going on.
I think some people are
still recovering from I/O,
and kind of taking that
time back, and saying,
OK, well, let's put a pause
on some of the conferencing
and see where maybe hopefully
some personal travel, or maybe
some quieter times, lay.
MICHELLE CASBON: I'm
definitely looking forward
to being in Europe this week.
I lived there a few years ago.
I lived in Germany, and I
haven't been back in a decade.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Oh, wow.
MICHELLE CASBON: And so
I'm really looking forward
to connecting with
some old friends
and having a little
bit of personal travel
in between a few
work-related things.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: I think
that's the right way to do it.
MICHELLE CASBON: Yeah.
Oh, one other really exciting
part of my Europe trip--
guess where I get to go?
MARK MIRCHANDANI: More
than Barcelona and Germany,
I have no idea.
MICHELLE CASBON: So
this is something
I've been wanting to do
for almost my entire life,
but I finally, finally, finally
get to go take a tour of CERN.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Oh, that's right.
MICHELLE CASBON: So I get to see
everything that Michio Kaku was
talking about in his session.
I get to see much
of it in person.
Atom smashers,
particle accelerators,
all kinds of things--
I'm so excited-- in
person for the first time.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: I mean,
this is a dream come true,
for you, it sounds
like, and probably
for a lot of other people.
MICHELLE CASBON:
It is fantastic,
and I have a few friends
coming along with me.
So we all get to
experience it together.
It'll be magical.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Well,
then, we will definitely
have you come back on afterwards
and talk a little bit about how
it was and all the cool,
super secret science stuff
that none of us have access to.
MICHELLE CASBON: I'll
tell you all about it.
Very excited.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: All right.
Well, perfect.
Thanks, everyone,
for checking in,
and we'll see you all next week.
MICHELLE CASBON: All right.
See you then.
[MUSIC PLAYING]